foreign
we're now going to talk so this
hypothetical question that I mentioned
in the opening about if we decided
suddenly to
focus on art as the fundamental basis of
our culture what would happen and would
we be poorer and less productive and so
on I guess it would mean if instead of
TED Talks being performed you know by
neuroscientists a vast audiences
suddenly they asked you know novelists
for what we should all do next and so I
wanted to turn to you James because you
have a antithetical view on this you've
written about how there's a lot of bad
art around so I wonder if we were being
legislated by really bad artists I mean
that might not be a good idea we there's
a slight notion in this that art would
fundamentally be you know lustrous and
you know high-minded but it could just
be a lot of really really terrible Arts
couldn't it well you know if if the
issue is you know whether we should be
led more by artists in them at the
moment makes me think back to um my
favorite idea from Aristotle is his idea
of the doctrine of the mean
and he says you know if you've got a
problem with with cowardice you aim to
be recklessly brave okay so if you're a
bit if you're a bit chicken you aim to
be just absolutely Reckless and you'll
probably end up roughly in the right
place okay if you're if you're a miser
right you just aim to give away all of
your money and you know hopefully you'll
end up in roughly the right place
um well the kind of society we are in at
the moment
um I think we should aim to be
completely led by artists just 100 okay
and maybe because because of the world
which is led by business and Science in
which there are multi-billionaires who
you know individuals who have more money
than an entire nation of of you know of
people I do not see that some you know
we're ever going to be able to get to a
stage where art is endangering our
industry and people's like desire to go
out and make huge amounts of money we
are so massively away from that so in
accordance with the doctrine of the mean
I'd say yeah let's go for a lot more
artistic influence on society and why do
I actually think that's important
because we're being
um you know our lives are being changed
by technology and technological
development and I think a lot of people
are not engaged with that process and
they buy into new technologies which
change our lives because it's fun
um and it's produced because people know
it will sell and that's kind of how our
future is being determined you know the
consumers saying it's fun and the people
producing it saying that'll sell yeah if
we had a little bit more artistic
engagement with our ideas and our facts
and our science and our philosophy then
you know a bit more like Palm edit is
going on through the sky on his Chariot
you know maybe people get a bit more
interested in these sort of things and
people you know you can have some kind
of democracy some kind of democratic
element enter into the process of
technological development that's why I
think it's important to get art involved
because it didn't engages people and I
think there's disengagement we just take
what's given to us by people working
behind the scenes I mean is it during
the pandemic I was thinking as someone
who works within performance and it
would seemed that people did have a real
craving for than those you know
performances of plays online and there
was that yearning for
even as we're being following the
science and all of that there was a
yearning for something artistic within
that was that something you noticed in
your own field yes
um and I think there's definitely a
place for that to carry on because there
are people who can't leave the house for
various reasons not to do with covid
um and they were able to watch a comedy
and various debates like this and plays
and so on from their own homes and I
think it's brilliant I think you should
carry on but performing stand up on Zoom
looking at a massive version of your own
face sometimes doing your material
sometimes to silence or the chat
function being open and seeing people
discuss what they were going to do next
well while you were on stage was odd
discombobulating
um however it was quite interesting to
go through as a performer and a writer
um and the pandemic did Force us to
think differently about how we how we
create art and what we do and even how
we write I was writing a book and I
wrote differently because I couldn't see
people but I suppose
um when you engage I I think it's
difficult not to engage with art so if
we did replace all the TED talks with
some kind of art even if it wasn't very
good art even if it was back-to-back
episodes of Married at First Sight I I
still think that
that would generate a response and even
if you're talking about why didn't that
relationship work and how does that
reflect on my relationship it's
different from watching something that
you feel very uh detached from
but it's interesting because what is bad
you can get if we did say everything has
to be art now you'd get such a wide
variety of things and such a wide
variety of of quality and there'd be
disagreements about what was good and
what was bad whereas science feels more
cut and dried what is bad science
communicate it's it's black and white
isn't it so it can't be an it well it
shouldn't be factual inaccuracies it
should be a a thing that's not relevant
to society but I think definitely we
should replace everything with art and I
think technology is
I I think it's very damaging the way
that we consume facts and that if they
could be communicated through ART we'd
think about the way we form opinions
differently and discuss our opinions
differently and perhaps come to
different conclusions but the way the
way especially with social media that
things are presented to us I think it
feels cold and you're disengaged and uh
I think that's the way that things
become more polarized as well yes I mean
yeah no if you do you think if if Sage
had had
um nothing but artists and you know
novelists on it instead of you know
scientists and behavioral scientists
what what on Earth would have happened I
mean what had had sorry if say sorry the
the you know the kind of Advisory Board
advising the government the scientific
Advisory Group which may you know
constantly advise the government during
the pandemic just finishing off on the
pandemic as an example I guess do you
think that would have been totally
different running of the pandemic if
we'd had artists I think quite a lot of
things would have been different because
I mean what artists have to do if
they're of course if they're any good
and that's what they saw you know is to
understand yeah what goes on in people
at a deeper level and try to communicate
that
um that really good art is always a
letter from the soul of the artist to
the soul of the recipient and that's no
matter what what kind of art we talk
about but it takes a little bit more
time than that stand-up conversation
that's had in politics or the everyday
debate but what I have don't understand
is
you know in a lot of schools I'm not
quite sure how it is here in England but
in Denmark you know morning song is
considered if you want to lift the kids
but why don't every parliamentary
session not start with the reading of a
poem
um it sets the tone totally different
that you have just in a way every
meeting in any business should start
with the reading of a poem because it
forces every participant to just reach
themselves who are they really as human
beings not as functions of a capitalist
system that needs to make money or a
voting system that needs to sell some
idea that they can get more votes and
more power it's all that idea of selling
goes away if you start having a to reach
your deeper human self and from there I
believe we take better decisions because
it's not that the poet or the writer or
artist themselves take better decisions
or give better advisors I mean history
shows many artists unfortunately have
been facets you know Amazon and Nazi and
whatever but they knew how to reach the
soul and when we reach the soul we take
better decisions
I mean so just to try and complicate
this distinction between Art and Science
a little Paul I mean I was thinking what
you said earlier about the fog and so
you create a notion of the fog and the
sort of Observer then creates a certain
version of what is seen and I guess
science has reached that Revelation in
some Fields hasn't it in the quantum
realm and the idea that the Observer
affects what's being observed and so
this kind of maybe form a distinction
between the world and the individual may
not be so polarized in Art and Science
could that be one way where we're not
just dividing them utterly
oh I I don't think that I mean they they
may not be divided that there may not be
divided
um you know I do think that you know as
we read anything
we're to go back to what I was saying
earlier we're constantly testing uh each
word each sentence with our our own
um
lived experience to use a phrase that's
much used these days including including
when we meet the word lemon
um in in in a in a work of literature as
we do by the way in gems Joyce's
Ulysses a lemon is a central component
uh resonating in various ways
um we tested against what we know
ourselves a lemon to be and then with
any luck actually we're pushed to a
place where we did not expect to be and
that may not absolutely square up with
the facts but I think there is a
relationship between the two and we you
know we can't we can't get to be without
having some sense of a I don't hope that
doesn't sound too nomic but there's some
we have to have familiarity
um acceptance of of a basic of assured
notion before we begin to play with it
so
um but I mean various things were coming
to mind there and as I said no I'm not
at all sure which side I'm on I was
interested by the way and then in the
notion of the good poem you know who
determines what a good poem is that's
going to be a a tough job that's going
to be a job for the Poetry czar
who will have quite a large office
somewhere right I mean because
um you know I love the idea of starting
the day with a poem I do love that idea
I love the idea of
um every newspaper in this country for
example just to stick with this country
for the moment should be carrying a poem
Every Day right one of the reasons why
that is the case is that what actually
diminish the notion that art is
something
strange mysterious something that we
can't all partake of in the way that we
might actually partake of
particle physics in a strange way I mean
and for some reason we think we might be
able to understand quarks better than we
might James Joyce that they're more
intelligible in some strange way though
the word Quark as you Quark as you know
derives from James Joys there's this
notion that um
that the The Sciences are indeed uh more
involved with facts which which is
simply not the case and I would love
more scientists to acknowledge that they
are involved themselves in surmises
and and that in fact they would honor
the creative aspect of science
right
um and Notions of what I think there was
a debate earlier on at 12 I didn't get
to Adam have read about whether or not
the notion of the the Multiverse is a
construct is actually something that
belongs more in the realm of the poem
than it might in the realm of what
the abacus
um I don't know yeah great I mean let's
turn now to where we think culture is
going which we've kind of touched on to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas